hey youtubers is Charlie oh my god we
got to break this poster in this title
down so there are a couple really big
things longtime Star Wars fans will
immediately notice some of the visual
similarities in this poster to a
previous poster from another Star Wars
film I've got a really funny clip of
Mark Hamill talking about his original
idea for Episode seven and then we got
to talk about when they're gonna drop
the first teaser there is a new round of
the Star Wars giveaway for IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a Star Wars
related comment on this video so just
very specific about what this movie is
going to focus on in the poster itself I
know it reminds you of Return of the
Jedi the title that was actually what
the teaser poster for Return of the Jedi
looked like and even revenge of the Jedi
before they changed the title to return
so the Easter egg in there is that a lot
of a tone of this red text implies that
it's gonna be a little bit darker than
the first film there's also going to be
a return of Luke Skywalker Return of the
Jedi so the force awakens was all about
the awakening of Rey's character in the
force in general and a number of other
characters so it was like the force had
been dormant for a long time although
not in the truest sense of the word and
it was coming back but now the last Jedi
just makes you feel like the whole movie
is gonna be about Luke Skywalker
because people wonder you know what does
that title actually mean the last Jedi
who are they talking about in his Jedi
plural because now Rey is training to be
a Jedi so the thing is is sometimes when
you look at the way they translate
posters and titles into other languages
you can find out what they intended
based on male or female pronouns so when
the posters they released in Brazil it
actually read male in singular so that
implies that the title is supposed to be
for Luke not for Rey and it's not for
both of them just because Rey is not a
Jedi yet she just meant Luke Skywalker
and in Empire Strikes Back Luke
Skywalker did the same thing where he's
like I'm a Jedi now in every other force
user that he was in proximity to during
that movie like Yoda obi-wan Kenobi
even Darth Vader said that his training
was not finished I'll complete your
training week
rule the galaxy together so luke
skywalker's like oh yeah I got some
training I'm totally a Jedi everyone's
just like nope not even close
so Rey is just beginning the path to
becoming a Jedi presumably she'll get
there by the third movie in the way that
Luke Skywalker finally became a Jedi
when he came to terms with his father
and helped save him so Luke Skywalker we
got to talk all about Luke Skywalker
Mark Hamill has said all kinds of funny
stuff about getting ready for the force
awakens like he lost a ton of weight he
got back into shape and did not know
that when he showed up on set all they
wanted him to do was just turn around
wearing these heavy Jedi robes and
pulled the hood back he said he was a
little upset he was excited to be back
for Star Wars but he was a little upset
because he'd been prepared for this big
action set piece because he thought that
he was going to enter the movie when han
Solo was killed his idea was that he
would actually come see his friend die
and it would be more meaningful my
problem with that death was I said why
does that you know what should happen
there's no character that really besides
Chewie that has a real deep connection
to him so it's his his death doesn't
have the resonance that it would have if
Leia witnessed it or if Luke was rushing
back to save him and was just not you
know too late because I thought as I was
reading that I said oh you know she's
trying to contact me and in the earlier
films she could do with the ESPE and I
said I know that I'm not showing up till
the end I'll betcha I'll show up like
Han coming back at the beginning of the
first one to the Death Star I'll show up
in the last nine minutes but I'll be
just too late for to save Han but I'll
allow the new protagonist to succeed
believe me I didn't know it was just
gonna be a pivot and a good removal I
mean I trained twice a week for 50 weeks
for that I thought well I'm gonna do
something great okay I mean I lost all
this weight and then they put me in
these robes I said I don't know anyone
so I could be Jabba the Hutt in movies
it's always so funny listening to the
original cast sort of talked about what
their thoughts on the film are outside
of the film itself like you know usually
you expect them to hype it up but they
have their own ideas about it too in the
idea of the wasted Mark Hamill
ah sorry that could have happened in
Episode seven but that will definitely
not happen in Episode eight because
since Rian Johnson's been shooting it
they've actually posted a couple behind
the scenes images they've been so
hardcore about security it is ridiculous
what Mark Hamill says the security is
like they wear security robes over their
normal clothes but they have released a
picture of Luke's clothing this staff
here you just you don't see a lot of
stuff out here you just see a little bit
about the way that he's a lived this
whole time while he's been in isolation
so back to the title again the last Jedi
Luke Skywalker you have to imagine that
he's the last that was trained by
traditional Jedi and now that he's gone
back like the whole big thing about this
new trilogy isn't getting back to what
the original intent of the forces like
the original interpretation that was
perverted over time by both the Jedi in
other factions like the Sith so you have
smoke on one side you have Luke on the
other that both are trying to take a
different interpretation of the force
than they were taught previously I know
there's even less information about
Snoke but I actually think that that's a
good thing we didn't really learn about
the Emperor until Empire Strikes Back
and then really didn't get to see him
that much until the final movie so I am
totally cool with that same paradigm but
if you haven't been watching it Star
Wars rebels has been doing this really
interesting thing with the way it
reinterprets the force they just did
this big dark saber episode they
actually brought Knights of the Old
Republic back into the Canon put you
know previously Knights of the Old
Republic Darth Revan all that stuff
almost made it into the Canon during
Clone Wars George Lucas pulled like a
hard pass was like no put Darth Bane in
Darth Revan
out so Knights of the Old Republic was
not canon that all changed this past
weekend another thing they did earlier
this year with the interpretation of the
force was bring back the Ben do George
Lucas's original name for the Jedi in
the way the Ben do tells it he practices
the force a very different way there's
the light side the dark side I'm the one
in the middle so I don't think that says
outright that Luke is turning into a
grey Jedi or anything like that I think
in searching for the Ock to planet
that's the name of the planet that he's
on in
the original Jedi Temple he just seeking
to find the truth of things that he felt
was lost over time so one of the most
exciting things about this one obviously
the title says Jedi so there's gonna be
a shitload of Jedi stuff happening in it
but - we'll also get a lot of new
mythology that will reinterpret and
recontextualize a lot of the old movies
- they did that during rogue one with
the Death Star weakness where it's like
there's this you know really funny story
beat that doesn't totally make sense why
would the Empire build such a crappy
design well turns out it was on purpose
so that Jin's father could aid the
rebels and they'd be able to destroy it
so just think of the way they're
treating the force in these new movies
is doing that for the force in the
previous movies - that's why you don't
hear about midi-chlorians or anything
like that Luke himself is going back to
rewrite a lot of that cannon in Rey is
going to learn it the right way so
should be a very different kind of Jedi
once she does complete her training but
the cool thing is that on the other side
of that so will kylo Ren it's implied
that the same thing is happening with
Snoke right now now he doesn't have the
information that Luke has but presumably
he has a lot of dark knowledge that has
nothing to do with the Sith because they
said the Sith isn't really a thing in
the new trilogy now all religious orders
all over the galaxy haven't been wiped
out there's probably a couple people
that still believe in the Sith somewhere
out there is just that Snoke and kylo
Ren are not part of the Sith that's just
the way they explain it going into the
force awakens so you guys can let me
know what are you most excited about
seeing the new force abilities in the
new force lore that Luke Skywalker has
learned about or about the stuff that
Snoke is teaching kylo Ren because most
of the force powers that kylo Ren
displayed in the first movie and even
Daisy Ridley's character we're
rudimentary you know Jedi mind-trick
things that you saw in Episode four
pretty basic stuff pretty basic
lightsaber fight I'm not expecting to
see any of that in whatever the first
teaser is but a lot of the language that
they use implies some of the path that
they'll be taking so the first real
trailer is probably not going to drop
till Star Wars Celebration in April but
because they released the title the t's
our poster for the force awakens right
before they released the first teaser
they might also release a short teaser
really soon now like not this month but
maybe next month maybe in March so just
be prepared for some actual Star Wars
Episode 8 footage to drop but what's
gonna happen is is just because now it's
time to start freaking out about Star
Wars Episode 8 I'll be doing a lot more
bonus videos please leave all your
requests for what you want those to be
about in the comments tomorrow I'll do
another bonus video about new Luke
Skywalker powers the nature of the force
just talking about more Jedi specific
stuff so that should post in the morning
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my dark side Rey
video and you can click here for the
greatest Darth Vader scene in the
history of cinema thank you so much for
watching everybody
what's my bottom I'll see you guys
tonight mini-me
[Music]